interesting guy has some things that I  don't agree with what don't you agree  with I think some of the things that he  says especially about financial side  you're broke treatment a woman I'm like  man that's like pushing it can you give  me an example of something that he says  about women that you disagree with the  fact that  let me think  because he's so picky about like having  someone with no body count so would you  marry a woman that slept with over 50  men I wouldn't personally because I've  been married before and divorced so I  wouldn't so that's what Andrew take says  he says body count matters you have to  be selective I think so I think so we  agree with Andrew I would say I agree  with him on majority of it